i remember meeting you back in the mid
90s and i had all this
i had long hair i was looking you know
crazy where's that roseland this club
called rosella i said mike now tony i'm
tony touch how you doing he said tony
touch
looked me up and i said man tony touched
the dj
yeah you make the tapes i thought you
was black
i had no idea i said listen puerto
ricans like the same [ __ ] anyway but
[Music]
here we go one two one two another
episode of hot boxing and mike tyson
i'm evan britton and we have an awesome
guest extraordinaire the masterman the
mixtape
king tears only tears ah
hey i love that let me catch my breath
thank you man mike thanks for having me
man fresh off the plane
yeah i'm glad to hear that i just landed
literally like
not even an hour ago it's a good
welcoming just a good welcoming right
here i like that man
good thing the airport's close yeah yeah
it's amazing you know it was like
everything worked out perfectly it's
called blessing we're so
close to the airport amen man what are
you doing tony man
man uh a lot of great things happening
bro
this new a mixtape thing you're doing
three yeah it's a mixtape
film we're putting together we're
talking about the whole mixtape culture
from the beginning
hollywood bruce you know brucy b
starchow all the way up through kick
capri into dj
khloe and kay slay all the way up to now
to
drama dj khaled you know we want to show
people um
how important the mixtape culture was
man for many years because you know
music wasn't really on the radio
for a long time too though yeah drama
kick the drama yeah that's right man
he's in atlanta now right
yeah he kicked that for a long time and
he took the rap man for
you know when the feds came down on the
whole thing mixtape
yeah he was he was he was the you know
he was uh the dude that ended up getting
hemmed up
for it man yeah so it changed everything
since then but this he's still
successful he's got his studio his label
his
artist so we want to talk about that
because yeah for a while the mixtape dj
was like the underdog you know we wasn't
on the radio really
in the limelight but we were really
spreading the music all over the world
i know but you're spreading the
different kind of music you were
spreading them cultural music
music that they would never play on the
radio music that
really would never they played rap music
but it really never put out
our word how we expressed ourselves how
we spoke
you know what i mean even listen when
you think about it now rapid
the light was really commercial when you
think about wrapping up that was really
sold out rapping music when you really
think about it commercial yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's what you're doing
who's also in the film who wrote the
sugar hill
yeah listen listen nwa came in with
those other
guys books with bill and those guys they
came and changed the game
they said they spoke for us um public
enemy they spoke for us they changed the
game
they sure did the people then they they
told our secrets they even knows how we
feel now
everybody knows about us everybody
conducts themselves somewhat like us
because they
that's the culture that we were you know
we were just so taboo we were so
taboo our parents didn't like us we were
different from our parents
and then hip-hop come and then hip-hop
came and we
everybody if you're not with us with
this our parents everybody
and we have built this culture yeah
that's right
here we are man it's amazing 20 you know
20 20.
it's amazing come the latin quarter
that's what the play listen
i can remember and like 83 and stuff
like the 85 83 stuff
if you're hanging out in those places
you're a scum
you know what i mean even your friends
you come around you i heard you was at
that place with that hip-hop bee bop
my yo mike that's just crazy you're
listening you were the outcast if you
you lit hung around the hip-hop spots
latin quarterback was the other the
tunnel you hung around there all the
people there was the stick of kids the
criminals were there so you hung up
there you were really in bad
you're bad news that's right man i went
to lqs once
yeah it was crazy right 87.88 it was
crazy right shout out to red alert who
was
he probably he took you that he did all
the time every time i went there i saw
red alert that's right man i got to
dj with him uh this saturday night man
he's still kicking ass
man let alert man that's dope prop
master
prop master that's right yeah so now a
lot of good things happening so there's
plenty of movies out there
hip-hop films and documentaries about
rappers or
you know this that and the third or dj
stuff even but
this is a really deep story about how
how important the mixtape culture is so
listen let me tell you something this is
how i got involved with mixed tapes
yeah the first time i ever in my life
forever i never heard
i'm up in um i'm in bronx i'm in
juvenile detention center called spartan
in the bronx
and i hear people talking about these um
grand master flash
theodore galore i'm the l brothers
grandmaster mellie mouth
who the [ __ ] are these guys man get the
[ __ ] out of here they come around here
and get killed the robbed [ __ ]
they saw you crazy and these guys like
this and that that's i can't they could
have never had nothing
then one day when i came back home
someone gave me a tape
of some people from the bronx wasn't
grandmaster flats but it was shaw rock
and the churches three at churches four
something like that
and the girl the shot rock don't stop
his kid on the mic and i was letting
everybody hear this
and then i got another one from grand
master flash one of these guys i was
locked up with
and this is spa sparta is in the bronx
yeah they're in the bronx
that's how i met those guys
yeah that's where it all started bro
yeah and i didn't even know nothing
about these guys what the hell
i see some guys in brooklyn they come
out and play music they don't say who
they are and they don't break
playing music they can't get on my hey
cut that [ __ ] out no fighting all right
but then they just get played to me but
these guys say who they what
[ __ ] i'm the king of rock
you know they talking [ __ ] and like
gangster real and all the gangsters hung
out there
all the i'm the [ __ ] outcast the
people that are stick up kids the people
that pickpockets the jostler
the chain snatches the robbers the heart
off the arm rob
everybody was there so that's why that's
why in the beginning time there's always
beef at the rap thing because everybody
you might see a guy that stuck you up
before [ __ ] at the music stand then
there's beef that's how it's always a
beast that started off that way with a
lot of beef and fights at the place
always something man you remember and
i'm going back home when i say that
right yeah
somebody just robbed you set this
[ __ ] club in my neighborhood and your
neighbor's not get my boy let's get
these [ __ ]
that's some union square [ __ ] yeah for
real union square
that's amazing that was beautiful too
right wasn't it
that was hip-hop at its finest man the
beginning stages man wasn't even 20
years old
50 wasn't 10 years old i know man shout
out kenny parker from boogie down
productions
he's djing with me tomorrow at my
tuesday party called toca tuesday's
yeah that night krs was the most
conscious cj he putting on me
he put you up on game put you up on the
universe and what's really going on
after we die he's one of
us that's right all right he's still
rocking
that's dope man it's amazing krs one
here too
it's amazing how the music captured the
energy
of this community you know
wow it brought all these people together
yeah and it spreads like wildfire
if you go from a religious perspective
even from
a muslim perspective about christians
back to this is the devil's work
can you believe that yeah can you
believe that that's [ __ ] can you
believe that
has been called that can you believe
that that's right all the devils when it
when
when michael the angel left he took all
the [ __ ] entertainers with him you
got to hear that but
so all the music is devil's music now
can you believe they put that in my mind
for thousands of [ __ ] years
it's crazy right crazy wow man
can you believe that yeah can you really
believe that as human beings we really
believe that
they try to take our [ __ ] happiness
our pleasure and they talk about
brainwash
yeah brainwash look how many years the
um religion had a brainwashed before
music
music even came to existence wow man
yeah but we're blessed man well you know
and we're
god blesses no no no man curse no way
look at this
killing it out here all of us killing it
tony tell
us something and get him bigger and
bigger and
famous unstoppable 20 50 years from now
a rapper make jay-z look like nothing
100 years from now they look like
nothing compared from the rappers that
coming
coming after us that's right the
fighters coming after us
crazy the podcast coming after us
we're gonna be nothing we'll be obsolete
you're right man tony give us a little
history of the mixed hate like how did
it come into being why was it necessary
well in the beginning the first tapes
that were really done were like
live recordings at parties and stuff you
know when yeah they were good too they
were like
they weren't that clear they weren't
that clear but they were good yeah it
wasn't no djs making tapes it was just
recordings from the parties you know and
um
you know that's where you heard the busy
bee yeah shantae
mc shantay all the shots
so you know i'm talking about that so
all the early recordings and then moving
forward
once dj's got equipment started making
tapes at home and customized tapes and
personalized and it just turned into a
thing where
it became big industry you know what i
mean and um it was like one of the best
ways
for artists to get heard and and labels
to get their music out there sometimes
you know
there was not a lot of radio
opportunities god would say listen
i got um dj clue yeah no no kid caprice
i got kid capri tape i said what
kicking pretty's always on the radio but
he never did a tape you always hear
rabbits so let's look at this thing
his tape is off the [ __ ] hook he's
talking like he's never talked before on
the radio he's talking to you personally
from the streets
that's right and he's a big part of the
film too capri because he like changed
the game like he took it from the
the homemade live park stuff to like
people come there then come see him
perform yeah
and so it started the industry man and
you know some call us pirates and
bootleggers and this that in the third
so there's a love-hate relationship with
the labels
and the dj's that were doing this stuff
so we talk about we just talk about it
so that's why you said the feds got
involved because it was looked at as
some sort of piracy
yeah i mean abs eventually somebody got
somebody had to deal with but how is it
piracy this [ __ ] was made up
i know this piracy get the [ __ ] out they
want to control it mike
you can't control they want to control
them can't control it
the only thing they can do is to control
the people who create his mind and make
them think that
these people are stealing from which we
are not that's right
like all these big-time stuff and this
[ __ ] is throwing some [ __ ] on
he's stealing money out of my [ __ ]
baby you [ __ ] idiot he's not
sure man so i mean yeah man you know
what i mean they think
they want to actually beat this guy up
for some of their tapes on the street
crazy
yeah the artist that's not the artist of
people in the school
to beat these guys up yeah hey but mike
uh on you know
one of the reasons too man i wanted to
come out here was it also
i'm glad we're talking about the film
you know because i remember meeting you
back in the mid 90s
and i had all this i had long hair i was
looking
you know crazy it was at roseland this
club called rosella i said mike ma'am
tony i'm tony touch how you doing he
said tony touch
looked me up and i said man tony touched
the dj i was like yeah yeah
you make the tapes yeah yeah [ __ ] i
thought you was black
i had no idea i said listen i'm puerto
rican it's like the same [ __ ] anyway but
um you know uh we we hit it off from
then and you told me how
uh a lot of your training sessions your
workout sessions were like off of
mixtapes yeah
continuous plays so we wouldn't have to
stop working out
turn the dial up sometimes yeah
sometimes you run the [ __ ] say
some fly [ __ ] you got the whoa
stop
that's oh you get excited man yeah that
was how you turn that [ __ ] back yeah it
was an exciting time
that's another right rewind yeah the
rewind
now just press the button go back i know
are up and coming
artist musicians are they still making
mixtapes
now it's still being used but it's just
different names for it some people call
it playlists
okay you know because you got a playlist
that's what mixed together
youtube listening to a playlist because
i listen to music boomers put a play
that should be
it's a radio station that plays music
all day yeah
yeah so that's what like kind of like
they got the idea from us
with all of that you know what i mean
what they don't do
what they don't do they don't mix yeah
they play you know it's continuous music
but they ain't mixing like you're in
tune right
yeah yeah there's platforms out there
that djs use now to get their mixes
heard like there's a mixcloud.com and
soundcloud.com you got a lot of dj's
uploading mixes live from this club or
you know different formats and stuff so
it's it's still vibrant and the labels
still use it as marketing tools to still
get their artists even artists
themselves doing their own thing look at
nipsey hustle god bless you
god bless his soul you know he he did
this whole thing where he did like 100
mixtapes
yeah and sold them for like a thousand
dollars each
and and like that was like genius like
he had like such strategy strategic [ __ ]
and he was
a big supporter of the mixtape and you
know what this is this is the magical
mixtapes than any other tapes okay
um the mixtapes you never [ __ ] um
you never get tired everything that's on
there is what you want
everything's always soothing to you and
you know i mean your whole [ __ ]
existence
yeah everything you want nothing like
[ __ ] i don't want that somebody just run
to it anyway
no everything is soothing to you there's
nothing interrupting you your whole
existence is perfect at that moment
wow you know amazing thank you yeah i've
been there really you know that's how
you feel me though right
it's amazing everything you want is
there yeah
imagine having everything you want
that's an awesome feeling emotionally
too [ __ ] physically emotionally because
emotionally you have a physical it's
just
everything there musically yeah inspired
musically
music inspires people why does this
inspire you i know
we don't even know that about why does
this music in spite why does this make
you want to fight why does this make you
want to love why does this make you want
to just
be exhilarated i've thought about that
before myself
and it's all it's as if music is just
pure energy
because we just feel it yeah you know
we're not like
thinking about music and i've listened
to these uh tapes of this guy talking
about his name's alan watts
and uh he talks about how you know life
should be like
music because in music you're never
rushing to get to the end
yeah you're just enjoying every moment
of it as it comes
it's about the music itself something
else about music is really
people create it but no one owns it yeah
it belongs to no one they want to own it
that's the thing
you know um capitalistic where we want
to own everyone who owns our spirit on
the people's souls
music hopes to own people's soul and
their own perspective
yeah because when you hear music you act
outside of yourself
you do you hardcore god they never say
you know yeah [ __ ] you
you know and you find a way to make the
music adjust to your personality your
heart [ __ ] find the music you just
rock hard keeps you hard keep you cool
though but you know
i know sucker character or something you
know you find a way to adjust to it
and your personality wow man
it's a great story no it's real stuff
you can't even control yourself when you
hear a song yes life on
something you feel it in you can't even
control yourself you can't just stop
eating
yeah yeah you hungry
i know man you feel that energy that
vibration come through you dude
it's powerful yeah it's not feeling like
it man so we got these parties we do in
new york every week sunday nights it's
like deep soulful houses
uh the sunday night party now is at a
venue called chelsea music hall it's in
the meat packet district 14th street
nintendo remember that by nails used to
be nails yeah that area
yeah yeah and then we got the tuesday
nights at bar 13 which is across the
street from the old union square
got a rooftop and everything listen let
me tell you something i had to leave new
york i know why i had to leave new york
and i was kicked out of every [ __ ]
club
we kicked out every club you're useless
in new york why was this
you can't communicate and be kicked out
of all the clubs i was [ __ ]
nobody will let you in oh no i was a
wild man half a kid
fighting with the boss and bringing thug
guys down they ain't never had thug guys
done anything
[ __ ] these kind of clubs and stuff i
remember i think i heard a story at the
tunnel with big pawn and fight
yeah you guys trying to play big pun in
them right
and then what happened he's something
right you
dudes you're chasing some dude around
the [ __ ] van or some [ __ ]
yeah that's what i heard i don't know i
wasn't there this is true but
wow man
yo liz i was such a big listen i was
such a big fan listen man
listen god bless pun listen these guys
are like guardsmen
[ __ ] guys that are killers [ __ ]
savages would cuddle them for somebody
even
upset them they don't even know these
guys they just love them you know it was
like
it was like the [ __ ] ghetto it was
like ghetto superstars for the first
time people in the hood with big respect
with big fancy cars the police respected
them and [ __ ] it was crazy
and they didn't steal [ __ ] we still
robbed and ain't still [ __ ] they about
they're risking their life every day but
these guys living deadly
look at these guys live the way they
want to live just like that this is the
way to hustle dream
the rapper the successful rapper the
hustlers dream
he's the guys like us we're on the strip
we're out there hustling and trying to
get money
sticking up that's our dream that's what
we want we don't know how we're going to
get there but that's what
that's our picture that's the picture of
us but how do i get there from doing
this
i'm trying to get there with this
[ __ ] gun but how does this work
it's like two sides of the same coin but
then he starts getting involved with
this well i'm not a rapper
i could be a security card with the
rappers and the [ __ ] just moves on
bigger now he owns the company
some [ __ ] like shook did he's a security
guard now he owns the [ __ ] company
that's right a bodyguard that's crazy
company anything can happen man
you get so inspired by this [ __ ] yeah
yes yeah it goes man
you see this guy's on welfare food
stamps live in the condemned building
and next thing you know he's a mega star
he comes around the neighborhood and
rolls royces and bugattis and [ __ ]
these cars cause millions of dollars
hundreds of thousands these guys just
riding in the hood chilling out you saw
his mother with a bum a prostitute i
look at this [ __ ] guy
that's how the hood works
don't talk we come from [ __ ] next thing
you know in the [ __ ]
sky is it because you tap into your
what you're supposed to do no we get to
we we have we have a
we have an objective now that's a goal
this [ __ ] from down here he's
no better than me
he didn't go to school i didn't go to
school his mother's
trappy my mother were on welfare i
couldn't do it
yeah so you just see it you visualize it
these guys are still in the hood these
guys
they still think they're bad
[ __ ] they got their crew and
they still ride around the hood with
their [ __ ]
wish you tried to do some [ __ ] to them
yeah you serious that's how it is yeah
so still [ __ ] getting spies
[ __ ] i'm in the hood this guy got a
[ __ ] million out of car driving
around here
he's a rapper how do i get involved
you know yeah and then some of those
guys they're looking for guys that are
hungry wanting to get involved
they look for guys out in the hood
around their customs who they know
they want to put on it's all about being
at the right place and having the right
desire
you know everything's timing and
lifetime has a lot to do with it
that's right for sure
like my friends when i started making
them they never saw no [ __ ] like that
so they just started hanging with me and
i always knew them all my life so we
just hung out together
and everybody started next thing you
know i said you need a job because you
can't just hang out with me and have no
money
so i put them on the payroll and now
these all these guys got jeffy you don't
want no broke [ __ ] around you
every time they need a [ __ ] soda or
something they got to ask you for money
and then they get
you know they got to become men
you understand can you hang around these
[ __ ] men yes every time they need
something they gotta ask you for a
[ __ ] dollar or a quarter
we have to make these guys an ev
independent of myself
you know i could put them on the scene
but they got to be their old man
and that's how that [ __ ] crews go and
they go on their own way and they blow
up too
like you said most of these guys in the
rapping they all know each other because
they all helped each other one way or
another started out they were
friends and even after being friends
they [ __ ] had beef and they just went
their cell phone away they separate away
but they still made it
you know [ __ ] it happens everybody
we're all one everything is one
you know we're all connected even people
in china we never met we're all
connected
the birds the bees the [ __ ] trees the
rock we're all one
it's the universe it's interesting tony
i mean the first time
you heard about mike what was that
watching one of his fights oh yeah well
we're from the same neighborhood
yeah both from brooklyn so you guys it's
interesting how
you know you come into each other's
lives
yes wow you know over and over again
yeah we come from basically i'm from
brownsville we're in the same states new
york city we come from [ __ ] really
scary [ __ ] unimaginable places [ __ ]
you can't imagine
like you can never imagine that we gotta
walk up the [ __ ] stairs and hell
elevators not the [ __ ] elevator but
walk 20 20 flights and be careful the
[ __ ] you might meet in one of those
[ __ ] hallways
as you're going up the steps who you
might [ __ ] meet at 12 in the morning
one in the morning three in the morning
you gotta run upstairs some weird
[ __ ] doing drugs whatever
a cruel [ __ ] shooting dice up
there while you're coming upstairs this
[ __ ] is
crazy this [ __ ] is crazy over there man
but you know
how things have changed now in brooklyn
huh i can't believe it
it's crazy it's hard to believe that for
stops and you can't lift it the rent is
expensive as manhattan yeah
yeah my dad lives in fort greene that's
why i was born fort green
were you really yeah in cumberland
hospital wow me spike lee
michael jordan yeah spike lee's dad
lives right there all born in the same
hospital yeah
it's a big part mama big on
well why do you guys think so many
superstar
energy p you know people have come out
of that
area they've got inspired they've seen
people
close to them they've seen them seen it
happen to them they said he did it i
could do that
we used to be on the [ __ ] same line
for looking [ __ ] free for lunch [ __ ]
he's now he blew up
remember free lunch yeah now we're on
the same line waiting for the free lunch
right now this muffin on television all
over the place and planes and [ __ ]
driving fancy cars riding around the
neighborhood
i can do that [ __ ] too let me take this
dope money let me
flip this [ __ ] around now i can do this
[ __ ] too
cause most of those guys in the street
they got more money than a lot of these
celebrities just don't know what to do
and they kiss me they have to make chill
out let me keep got more money than
these guys let me kissing that [ __ ]
ass like that
jocking on them but they don't know you
know they don't understand because they
they don't feel good about themselves
having illegal money and [ __ ]
but these guys these guys are major
superstars themselves and they went
legit they would be a major
future 500 company from forbes man these
guys are geniuses
superstar hustlers yeah incredible how
can they make that fortune these are
kids
they got so much [ __ ] money they
can't even put it in the [ __ ] door
breaks open and they'll crush them
you know these guys they're just street
kids a trip man
tony i mean you've been you've worked
with the the best in the biz man
wow man yeah it's been a it's been a
great run with jay z
like i've never really worked with jay
you know
crossed paths a few times you know and
it's all love and cool about it
this guy whose guy was clueless who was
this guy
clue was yeah they did the album with
clue yeah that was a real successful
mixtape album you know
shout out to dj clue and they did a
great thing with that you know who
[ __ ] put it down for a minute
that's right yeah yeah he's still doing
his thing he's up on that yeah
y'all got power 105. clue's still uh
doing his thing so yeah that's another
part of the film man we talk about we
like what are you saying we still here
man like you got to endure a lot of [ __ ]
when we come from scotland
did you know scotland god bless him man
his son don't be coming yeah he's the
fly guy back in the day
yeah i never met him man god bless him
but his son his son be coming through
though
looking good doing this thing
here we are man so on top of the film
you're gonna do a mixtape as well right
yeah yeah there's a album like a
soundtrack to the film and um what that
is
is basically he's gonna be on the um
soundtrack
what was that who's gonna be in the
soundtrack uh well it's a def jam 35
year anniversary
um album that we're doing or like a
soundtrack
in conjunction with the film so it's
going to be like a lot of the def jam
guys artists and stuff like that and
uh you know two chains and you know
that's cool logic
we have logic here yeah yeah logic yeah
yeah yeah he's great man so um you know
kind of like classic meets current you
know
we're gonna revisit some classic def jam
beats and um
and maybe get some of the newer cats to
like rhyme on them classics a little bit
and
and vice versa you know get some of the
maybe the classic artist to wrap up
oh man i mean it goes way back to like
rock steady crew days and watching crazy
legs and
kids like me you know hispanic kids bad
kids right every the dances
yeah yeah you know so spanish kid like
me seeing these kids on screen like
inspired me you know wanna
just embrace hip hop as a whole so
originally i'm a b-boy
and turned dj turned you know producer
emcee whatever but
um it started with dancing for me shout
out voodoo ray my brother ray
you know another active uh dancer in the
community and that's what we represent
listen um i'm a new yorker and i
remember when this had came out so
you had a bunch of dancers right if they
had really some kind of beef with you
they wouldn't fight you but they had a
crew but they had the fighting spirit
the energy of fighting
when they were dancing with each other
yes and it was just and sometimes
other people would get in the fight
because it was just so crucial to
disrespect grabbing your ball putting
your head in the boat
you're doing something crazy man yeah
they make some other people fight that's
right that's where i get my drive from
that dance [ __ ]
but you'd settle [ __ ] right yeah we
started through the dance and at the end
they might slap each other five or three
is make yours
feeling good knowing they win but i
remember that's off the [ __ ]
chain [ __ ] yeah the dance off they have
the biggest
um [ __ ] brawls in the morning that's
fine
somebody have a stereo yeah or even
turntables
boom box that's [ __ ] and they're
cruising the crew that's coming around
battling people saying i'm the best in
the [ __ ] city
yeah that's what you started out as
well that's what drew me to like the
culture like i was like i want to do
this you know and then i was like oh
[ __ ] what's that dude
over there doing because no listen
because while they're doing it it's a
crowd around them they're not just not
doing it and people are just walking by
the crowd and now they're com now
they're [ __ ] performing yeah
showing their [ __ ] off that's exactly
what they said
now they show [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
grabbing balls flipping
dropping their pants all type of [ __ ]
flying in the air
that's right some of these guys in the
[ __ ] air man
incredible you think they're after backs
or something yeah
it's kind of like the beginning of that
parkour [ __ ]
have you seen the parkour where guys are
jumping off buildings and stuff and
landing on staircases hey let's check
this [ __ ] out i want to see this yeah
let's see this [ __ ] well it it the way
that they
move these guys it reminds me of how
break dancers move
crazy ass white people out here
me and my friend was saying you know you
know running up the steps how you
getting [ __ ] means running steps and
stuff i said i bet you some crazy ass
white boys made that [ __ ] running
together
say yo man almost got a heart attack you
saw that [ __ ]
all right free running how do you look
at this look at this [ __ ] look at these
people
they're spiderman outfits yeah
can you believe this man
[Music]
listen man back in the 80s i could see a
[ __ ]
breakdance of doing [ __ ] yeah yeah i
could because they know how to fall
you know how to fall and move and hit
the ground crazy
we can too right now we can be doing all
the
time
thank god yeah it's dope though right
yeah the way they move reminds me of
break dancers for some reason
right listen man you can't imagine
that's true man these guys do the most
death defying [ __ ] if you try you think
they're gonna kill themselves
yeah for them guys to do the flips and
the
the [ __ ] splits and yeah that's
another level now how do they
how do you learn to do that how do you
teach yourself that they've never been
to school they can't afford to go to
school how do you teach yourself that
yeah you just are in the park working on
[ __ ] any at home
everywhere you are you're just working
on like how can i
stress my body another way but it looks
like if you make a mistake you're going
to die
yeah if you make a mistake i think
you're going to die
people do a lot of stuff if you make a
mistake you're going to die
man that's right
tyson cush [ __ ] i'm not good weed huh
wow [ __ ] man what else are you doing man
are you in the cannabis industry at all
um
you know not necessarily i mean i still
do a radio show on sirius xm shave 45.
what's that about tuesday nights on
shave 45
um the eminem station that we're on
sirius xm
yeah so i got my tuesdays there for
about uh maybe 14 years now
um nice it's a great show we premiere a
lot of artists we've broke
many artists and we still play
underground music and all that
like anything goes you know what do you
think who's the biggest artist now
oh wow sure um
hmm it's not like you that man who used
to be
michael jackson that's a trick question
yeah yeah i mean whitney houston
yeah amadan you know who's the biggest
yeah rick springs yes
you would know right away yeah yes i
have a favorite
who's your favorite krs one oh he's the
[ __ ] bomb though no matter where you
go any part of the world like you know
you run into him or he's performing
somewhere he's just an awesome energy
huh
turns it you know he turns it up man so
for me that's my favorite i can't
you know the biggest maybe i guess maybe
you know to me him i guess
yeah i feel you yeah if i'm gonna go
there you know but uh
what about you what's yours who's yours
oh who do you feel
who's my biggest who really yeah your
favorite are you the biggest i don't
know how you wanna
[ __ ] i don't even know um i like raw kim
i like public enemy you know i like that
stuff too
that's like my um
cannabis cannabis but that's not that's
not my he's not my
my forefront and [ __ ] hip hop though
those guys like rock kim and those guys
um um [ __ ] run dm like him yeah
i love this it's better than that though
conscious rapper
latin quarters tupac tupac is pretty
awesome too
yeah biggie biggie's the best yeah
biggie yeah great
all of them man you know so many legends
guru
he was good too i love google miss him
you know he put me on like to a lot of
stuff like too
he's a nice guy i met him a lot of work
man you know and uh
pun [ __ ] so man oh love him love him
yeah man yeah nah this is [ __ ]
awesome
nice honor the best
well dope brother well we appreciate you
coming in
yeah it was great man you guys got me
high listen
i don't know how do you how do you
define the best within rapping
how do you do i don't know you find them
from generations from their time span or
just do you say who's the best i've ever
heard
it's like fighting you can never tell
who's the best yeah on a good night any
rapper could be the best
that's right yeah you don't know who he
is one night anybody give their best
it probably won't be the guy you think
is the best that night that's right
yeah i mean it's just what you're
feeling in that moment
i guess yeah depending on the mood i
guess yeah you're right
yeah well that's true this is true
great episode mike that's always a good
one this is nice we're smoking talking
tony great to have you man great to meet
you brother
man yeah you're the man that's amazing
look out for the film everybody what's
the title yeah yeah yeah we're in a
working title okay
place right now guys got that tucked
away but
awesome um you know what what do you
think how's the world of [ __ ]
mixtapes dealing with the world of
[ __ ] the um
the comp the podcast [ __ ] you know what
i mean yeah yeah the digital age
yeah that's what we're you know we're
gonna discuss and talk about how it's
evolved basically
it's like it's just evolved it turns
into that now you gotta
learn how to make the internet or
whatever you gotta make it work for you
you know yes
don't be a slave to it if that's what's
happening well listen i'm gonna learn it
and try to you know come up off it or at
least stay relevant or at least
find a way to just get it off you know
yeah and make the internet work for you
which is what basically
so during your life people more so knew
about your work than they knew your face
huh
how did they start knowing your face i
guess you know i would say after like i
put out that album in 2000
on tommy boy records i had this uh major
release album it was pretty it did
pretty well it's called the peacemaker i
don't know
we did a video with total remember total
uh the rap group from puffy though yeah
yeah probably yeah so we did that
we did that song and that single and you
know i kind of opened up
a lot more doors you know because it was
like my first mixtape album
so i had a bunch of artists on that
album you know pun god bless the soul
proof
eminem you know a lot of people on it so
um
it was like a mixtape album it did well
and that's really what really like
you know
yeah yeah yeah i got my weekly events in
the city and then i travel on the
weekends man one
one week and we could have a season your
weekly gig in the city is the place
where all the people all ages go or just
yeah yeah yeah
i don't know where to go in new york i'm
in new york i stay in the [ __ ] hotel
or the house
where i'm staying cause i don't know
where to go no more it's the [ __ ]
thing in my mind i own new york i don't
know the [ __ ] girl i'm scared to go
out now i don't know the [ __ ] god
we got to say that i don't know anybody
i'm looking to [ __ ] around i'm scared
the [ __ ] yo nah nah we got this event
once a month
once a month in new york it's called the
originals and it's me dj clark can't
stretch on clock stretch um
rich medina d nice bdpd nice so
it's fine i know him i used to have a
girlfriend right in the same building
with him
yeah back in the day that's when we were
younger i knew everybody back then
now go to this place i know where to go
so we do this party once a month
all of us for like seven years now and
the dj's are bringing in a hundred
thousand sixty thousand people crazy
right yeah it's a whole thing man it's
the whole movement
it's crazy bro here we are bro imagine
maddening the dj's in the front and i
remember they used to always be in the
back
that's right dj now the [ __ ] guy's
out front hell yeah
tony touch baby yeah once in that house
that's what's up man all right mike
great episode my brother
smoke on everything all day every day
smoking
anything you want people to know like
where they can find you instagram any of
that stuff yes
at dj tony touch everything facebook
instagram twitter
that's right you have a story about your
life and all the [ __ ] you've seen
the next movie you know all right
everybody
remember to subscribe on youtube to our
channel hot boxing with mike tyson
i'm evan britton i'm mike tyson tony
toca
we're over here all right
that's what we do tony that was what's
up man i lost my phone or something yeah
i look at my [ __ ] i don't sit
[Music]
[Music]